[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bring in chris mannix here uh we got a
lot of nba stuff happening but it's
happening off the the floor here let me
start with the nets with kyrie irving
and let's assume that he continues this
stance he's not getting vaccinated
what's going to happen here is he
tradeable chris
he is
largely untradeable i would say i don't
think anybody
is completely untradeable but
the teams i talk to
around the league about kyrie's trade
value
are
essentially operating under the
assumption that if you trade for him
there's a decent chance he'll just
retire and decide doesn't want to play
anymore
as a player there are lots of teams that
would love to get their hands on him he
has
a relatively reasonable contract with
only one
year left on it you can opt out after
next season
uh but the off the court stuff and the
uncertainty surrounding what he wants
um
that makes it him very very difficult to
trade
what is this costing him financially or
what could it cost him
well my understanding is
that
i don't know what
what if anything the nets are dinging
him for missed practices this week i
don't know if they're doing anything you
know they don't have he's not breaking
their rule he's breaking the city
ordinance
um or the executive order whatever you
want to call it so i don't know if
they're digging him anything but my
understanding is that
if he misses i believe it's friday's
pre-season game in brooklyn
it's around 380 000
and
will be 380 000
every time
he misses the game and the nba has been
very clear if players
miss games
because of
uh these city ordinances uh they are
going to get fined they will not be paid
you know effectively game checks as a
result of it that is
in his own words exactly why andrew
wiggins decided to get vaccinated uh
this week he didn't want to lose
all that money so if kyrie decides to
sit out the big ding comes when
that first game happens on friday
and if he can't play these home games he
also can't play
although it'd be one trip to san
francisco uh he can't play he's not
gonna play in the games against the
knicks because that would have the same
ordinance uh yeah
it's not it's not applicable i don't
think in san francisco i think there's
an exemption for
road players coming in so that that game
i believe he could play him but he could
not play
in madison square garden um under these
these current rules it's look the nets
they have been
just hoping i think it's
basically crossing their fingers
that kyrie would come around to the
vaccine that's why they have done
everything possible going back to sean
marx's media availability about three
weeks ago
to defuse this situation they have been
hoping that the threat of losing money
which is not the net saying we'll take
away money it's the nba and the city
and the presence of kevin durant his
close friend james harden a fellow
superstar would convince kyrie
to get the vaccine to this point and
i've checked in with nets people
almost every day trying to get a grasp
on this to this point
that hasn't happened and
as espn reported last night and they're
right
the optimism is kind of waning here that
kyrie is going to get vaccinated by
friday and and that puts the nets in a
whole in a very weird situation because
not only dan
can kyrie not play in these games he
clearly can't practice and steve nash
said yesterday he has no intention of
like
moving the nets practices back to jersey
or wherever they used to practice in
near the meadowlands uh they have a
state-of-the-art facility in brooklyn
built a few years ago they're not doing
that for kyrie irving so this presents
really i mean we use kind of phrases
like this a lot but an unprecedented
situation evolving between kyrie irving
and the nets look if he feels this
strongly about it and doesn't want to
play and you know he's going to retire
and he wants to sit out the season then
fine i mean i i understand it if he
feels strongly about it i just don't
want this to be a uh yeah notice me and
i'm quirky i'm interesting and uh hey
all right i'm going to get the vaccine
you know i it feels like that's where
we're headed with kyrie as far as ben
simmons
ben is just sitting there has his trade
demand and all of a sudden he looks up
and goes wait a minute i'm losing how
much money
what yeah what kind of reaction is uh
going on around the league with ben
simmons
well
the question
team executives say to me isn't it isn't
the sixers resolve they're wondering
about right now because
the sixers have not moved off their
position that to obtain ben simmons
you've got to give up a lot you've got
to give us
either a player the equivalent of ben
simmons or multiple players that would
add up to the value of ben simmons that
has not changed over the last couple of
weeks as this you know uh the sit out by
ben simmons has happened and the sixers
position and i get it is that there's a
lot of volatility
at the top of the nba right now i mean
we don't know how portland's season is
going to start and what the blazers
mindset might be in december about
damien lillard and or cj mccollum we
also don't know if the wizards come out
of the gate slow with bradley beal able
to opt out at the end of the season will
they decide now is the time to deal deal
so it doesn't make any sense for
philadelphia to deal simmons right now
uh the simmons side though
like they've been told expressly that
these checks
they ain't getting that money back like
that's not something like a team that
trades for him can back pay him this is
gone like the money he lost in that
toronto game on monday 360 000
that's gone i don't know what the sixers
have been dinging him every single day
but that's gone that's why the sixers
did a pretty shrewd thing when they put
that money into escrow i mean i kind of
described in the column that it was
basically a piggy bank that they could
dig into whenever they wanted to and up
until about eight point two uh two five
million dollars and that's what they're
going to do over the next month or so if
ben simmons sits out till mid-november
he'll lose like seven and a half million
dollars out of that money so i think the
question that comes up i know the
question that comes up amongst people
around the league is just how resolved
is ben simmons to lose that kind of
money you could say well he made 57
million dollars in his career on court
he's a lot he's made more optical it
doesn't matter like that's
millions of dollars that is gone and i
think people are wondering just how long
simmons will be okay with that i still
don't understand this ben simmons plays
poorly he's mad that people expect him
to play great since he's one of the top
end players we keep hearing he's an
all-star and he's a defensive player of
the year
all of these great things and then he
gets sensitive and he wants to be traded
i i so what am i missing here with ben
like um
are there bad people here on the other
side with with ben and i know joel
embiid and doc rivers said what they
said but all right maybe they would be
an honest tough thing to hear but you
know when why doesn't ben simmons put on
his big boy pants and say you know what
i'm going to show you guys i i'm going
to i'm going to earn your trust again
instead of saying i want out trade me
well simmons position
is that the sixers don't want him back
because they want to continue building
on the ben simmons to lmb tobias harris
group they want him back to see him play
well over a couple of months get his
trade value back up and then deal him
away ben simmons just isn't down with
that i mean
all that being said
he's still getting paid like this is
your job you signed this contract you
didn't have to sign a long-term deal
with philadelphia a couple of years ago
you chose to and because of that you
have to show up regardless of what the
76ers ultimately want to do with you and
i agree with you that
you know this is not like philadelphia
committed some kind of cardinal sin
against him doc rivers said something he
most certainly regrets right now joel
embiid just says anything and some of
the stuff that comes out of his mouth uh
is definitely critical of ben simmons
but who cares i mean
if that's the worst thing the 76ers have
done to you
lots of other players have experienced a
lot worse including joel embiid early
during the process so
i mean simmons doesn't want to come back
because he thinks that if he plays well
by mid-december or february at the
latest he's gone but that's the price of
signing that contract and being paid
like a max player all right your uh
yearly laker uh prediction
title
design on earth
this gets clipped and i wind up i i
this is like
you know it's like the low-hanging fruit
to pick against the lakers this year
because i don't know how it works
and
a lot of people most of the people i
talk to around the league don't really
know how it works i mean the lakers
assuming anthony davis buys into playing
center they could be really good i mean
davis at the five lebron at the four two
shooters around westbrook
i can see how that works i can also see
how westbrook's presence makes them an
elite regular season team because
westbrook has proven he can win regular
season games basically on his own so you
can wrestle lebron rest a.d if injuries
come up you've got a player that can win
games but when you get into the playoffs
westbrook is a career thirty percent
three-point shooter like he's at 31
last season you you can't really get
around that and he's been at his best
when he has the ball in his hands in the
playoffs you want the ball in lebron
james's hands you want the ball at times
in anthony davis's hands you don't want
the ball in russell westbrook's hands
because that not since the days of
oklahoma city has that proven to be an
effective strategy in the postseason so
there are lots of reasons to bet against
the lakers this year okay
so that's the quote we're going to pull
i don't know i i i
lakers in the finals i'm going with that
lakers in the finals i if i'm wrong
everybody else is wrong too like i just
i've eaten that that lakers gonna miss
the playoffs
video for like four with it three years
now like every time it comes up it'll
come up so i'm gonna clip it today like
why would you ask christmas about the
lakers here's what he said and like that
comes up every single year when the
discussion turns into the lakers here's
one of our favorites from chris mannix i
think first of all spain is stacked i
mean they're a team with you know yeah
hey shout out pau gasol on a great
career hall of fame is next based
largely on your career with the spanish
national team all right here's uh one
more blazers sixers in the finals
okay
that's unedited i reject the idea that
we just randomly pull quotes from mannex
and then we play them endlessly
great offense to that yes mclaughlin was
that from 1977 or what year was yeah
when bill walton was there they faced
doctor jay that's a great call great
callback didn't there have to wasn't
there like a preamble to that blazers
sixers uh no we couldn't
ask me like a bold prediction of some
kind maybe maybe not who knows who knows
okay yeah all right yeah thanks yeah
thank you chris
you got it dan that's the great chris
mannix sports illustrated nba senior
writer